speaking of which like okay new topic I
hope we haven't talked about this maybe
we have before uh is it hard to make
friends in 2023 because what I don't
know what like okay I live by the
algorithm so I don't know of YouTube
shorts thinks that I don't have many
friends
but so it's like you've been watching
too many YouTube shorts uh you clearly
have no friends yeah so I've been
recommended uh a lot of shorts recently
just about like you know this [__]
streets interviews that uh uh that
happened and there's just been like a
bunch of shorts I've been recommended
about just people talking about do you
have any real friends or how many how
many real friends do you have in your
life right okay are you okay guys huh
are you okay I'm okay we need to hang
out alive okay you know I'm saying I'm
okay but I find it interesting seeing
all these YouTube shorts and uh I think
uh like villain Franco did a like news
article recently oh yeah like loneliness
is like [__] yeah yeah
yeah how like in this day and age more
like more I think I don't I don't know
if it's more men or just more people in
general yeah uh are more lonely and
single than their like in in like the
history of like
I'm not too sure about those statistics
right because it's like I think about
that
I love that okay I'm sorry I was like
you know my opinion yeah you know uh
facts uh
in my opinion those facts are
questionable yeah it's like I'm calling
this episode yeah because like you know
I feel like with like the social media
and everything right and the internet
and and we've had this conversation like
way way earlier on in a in a podcast
episode about like our online friends
considered real friends right yeah and
like I feel right but that's also a
point of contexture of like a lot of
people who are just like terminally
online do see online friends as like
real friends because maybe they don't
have like actual IRL friends I think we
should discern what you mean by online
friends that's something you've never
met or is it yeah well you know it could
be like uh you know someone you talk to
every day on like Discord or like you
know someone you uh talk to consistently
on on Twitter or Instagram and you know
maybe you've met them once IRL but yeah
you know for the most part you met them
online I think that changes for social
media that changes how you look I mean
just not to get stuck in the in the the
details here but I think if you've met
someone and then you talk a bunch online
yeah it makes way more sense because
there's like okay we've met up and
there's probably that expectation that
we'll meet up again but if you've never
met up and you're only talking online
then I think there is a question of like
okay well is that a real friend well
it's it's this is weird yeah I mean well
because there's a lot of people you know
even in our personal lives of like we've
only talked to them online you know
we've interacted with them online but
we've never actually met IRL yeah right
but that doesn't mean that they're any
less of a friend than say like us three
or anyone you actually meet irr yeah
okay so Theory here
um so I I was I was kind of memeing when
I said no but kind of like also half not
meaning yeah uh because uh we we we're
friends right we have a lot of friends
right we we're with social people right
but
um like kind of kind of like the vibe I
got from all of these Tick Tock uh
[__] YouTube short like rabbit who I
went through was that a lot of people
nowadays have acquaintances
um but there's very like the people that
you would actually call like your real
friends is like kind of like on the
decline okay so then what is the what is
the border between a friend and an
acquaintance that's okay that's that's
that's the real question right that's
the real question how many people in
your life would you actually consider
like a real friend versus someone you uh
someone you hang out with and where do
you draw the distinction in that right
and for me personally at least for me
it's someone that I can feel totally as
as an introvert right it's someone I can
feel totally comfortable just being
myself yeah and not fearing being judged
or having like having that little
barrier to be like having that little
voice to be like can I say this in front
of this person I don't know because I
don't know them that I mean I don't know
where their boundaries yeah I don't know
where their boundaries are so I don't
know how far I can push the boundary so
I can you know I can call you guys
[__] uh so whatever I know I'm like I
I know you guys can take it you've just
been downgraded to all queens sorry
sorry you're probably gonna have to uh
[__] beat that up because of
YouTube's uh YouTube law and everything
like that but you know some some people
you're still like feeling the water
about where your like boundaries are and
uh that to me is when I can call someone
like a true mate you know right right
someone that I can hang out with any not
just hang out but actually talk with uh
talk to them about anything and not have
to feel like I have to play a certain
let's say role like when we hang out so
is okay now is there okay because often
these surveys and stuff they ask not how
many coins is today how many friends you
have any close friends do you yeah yes
yeah so is that that's the barrier would
you say for you to be friends and then
what would a close friend be I I okay or
would you do you consider all friends
close friends I consider all friends
close friends how many how many friends
would you say then you have
because this is this is like a common
Yeah question that you also get asked in
these questions yeah yeah
um I would actually say I have quite a
lot of friends
um that I consider myself close with
okay I mean
I mean okay here's here's the thing for
example uh everyone who are invited to
my wedding was is at least like if not
like a very very close friend someone
that I consider pretty very very
comfortable and I had like like you're
in like the 40 50 plus range yeah I have
like it's okay so it's got the dog but
here's the thing I feel like really
really lucky but the reason okay so
compared compared to a lot of other
YouTubers and a lot of other twitch
streamers that I uh talk to online in
the online space I actually like keep
and I'm actually not too social on my
let's say professional side a lot of
twitch streamers are very very close
friends with their fellow streamers or
YouTubers or something like that and I
am an I am not someone who spends a lot
of time speaking to a lot of other My a
lot of other fellow creators unless
they're [__] you guys basically and I
realize part of the reason for that yeah
part of the reason for that is just
because I've kind of like with the
friends I have now with the friends I
have back home abroad and like the
people I feel close to I'm like at kind
of like not a cap but it's hard I'm
friendship doubt yeah yeah
it's hard to keep up with what everyone
is doing
sure you only have so much time in a day
and if if you're a close friend I
actually want to be a close friend to
you as well and that friendship takes
effort you know it does it does take you
sure I also think we have to acknowledge
that we're in a very unique position uh
where there are more people who let's
say want to talk to us then maybe we
want to talk to other people yeah
um not saying that like fans are friends
or anything like that but you know
there's always people kind of
approaching us or meetings you're always
kind of like even doesn't work or not
you know you always meet people so I
think having that stress removed from
you know we never have to I I've no I
have no concern in the world about am I
am I going to meet enough people I'm
like okay I'm gonna be too many evil now
right yeah so I think that that's
important to acknowledge when we discuss
this yeah um
uh in terms of loneliness in general or
lack of friendship in general that's
tough I think I I think male loneliness
is a male loneliness specifically is
higher nowadays yes if you ask how
people feel yeah I don't know loneliness
has to be a feeling right I mean it's
not it's not like a I mean you are we
don't just go around and be like gone
I've checked out your friend list you're
[__] lonely I have diagnosed you with
loneliness it's like people say they're
lonelier lonelier and I don't know what
that means does that mean they're just
unhappier and they feel them like yeah
but that's the thing right it's like
it's really hard to also we are not
Professionals in this thing this is
purely completely our opinion we are
really our prerogative yeah but we also
live in a lonely country so yeah exactly
exactly so yeah so like understand this
is completely our prerogative and you
know and many people can take this in
many different ways but like when when I
saw like the statistics of like oh
loneliness has gone up I'm like can you
like even quantify something that is
like pretty subjective like because you
know there's I'm sure there are people
who have two friends but do not say that
they're lonely because they're very
content with just having a small group
of friends and then there may be some
people who have maybe you know 10 or 20
years would say like oh but I don't have
100 friends so I'm lonely right I mean
it's loneliness I guess is what it's not
so much about how many friends you have
or whatever that is it's like it's just
like the quality of the Friendship yeah
well it's like if they they're asking
these people hey do you think you're
lonely and they're like yes and I guess
it doesn't matter how many friends or
whatever they have because you could
have 500 friends and feel you don't have
a deep connection with any of them right
and be lonely right yeah I'll be a very
popular person but feel like you can't
really connect to any of those people
um so I think it's it's kind of a
talking about how many friends you have
is not so much important I think a lot
of these when I've read all these stuff
a lot of them tend to be focused on more
like how many meaningful friendships
yeah yeah that's where a lot of people
uh not everyone but a lot of people get
their kind of core satisfaction or a lot
of the satisfaction in their life from
those like two to five people yeah who
are like these are the people you
probably turn to the most about a lot of
things yeah
um I think that's true for me as well
the more I think about it I'm like yeah
I I often don't want to talk about all
of my stuff to everyone it's like
there's probably a few people who I
would talk to about certain things more
more often than not right because you're
like I don't want to give everyone the
[__] run down every single time you
know I mean like you want someone who
gets it you're like all right let's
let's talk right yeah yeah yeah
um that being said I think that there's
a lot of
um the coronavirus definitely
kicked into high gear loneliness oh I'm
like a crazy scale also I think uh
people growing up now I've also had a
harder time like let's say especially
people who are like just leaving High
School yeah who then got thrust into the
coronavirus where they're like oh you
were supposed to go to college
um no you couldn't and now it's like now
you have to do zoom and it's like okay
well you missed out on a lot of very
important maybe uh social learning
opportunities and I think a lot of
people also just lost a lot of friends
during covert because you didn't even if
they didn't like fall out or anything
it's like you just didn't hang out and
that's like and I think as we get older
we realize uh that maintaining a
friendship is probably
the hardest part about having friendship
it's not about making friends it's about
yeah am I seeing this person enough to
be on like good terms or to feel like
we're actually friends and I think that
was the thing that was affected a lot
during the pandemic and it's kind of
snowballed and I and I think that that
to me is the big thing
that's all good points because like like
the reason I say that I mean I'm very
blessed I think with my friendship
groups that I found uh because one of
the big reason is we've we have hung out
a lot in the past uh I've moved country
now I've moved countries now so I don't
get to talk or hang out with them as
often as maybe when I lived in England
or you know when I lived in the same
country as them but I always there's
always that Mutual trust between the
both parties that when we meet up we can
still talk about anything nothing's
changing things can be completely
comfortable
um and that's like that's that's the big
differentiator for me
um when I finally understood what it
means to have like a lifetime friend you
know because everyone has different
[__] priorities is everyone's doing
different [__] in their lives you can't
always be next to your friend or be
hanging out every week everyone's
adulting everyone's adulting right and
to me an adult friendship is having that
trust and respect for each other that
you can you can have the same connection
even if even if you haven't talked to
each other for like a few months even if
we haven't seen each other for a year
yeah the moment you hang out you're like
[__] it's it's all it's all the stuff
that's definitely for me my distinction
between a friend and a good friend like
a good friend is someone that you can
like not text or call or interact with
for like months or even years at a time
and then the next time that a text or a
call or a meet-up is set it's like
nothing has changed yeah and you can
just go right back to where you were in
that same mentality of the last time you
saw them or the last time you called
them right yeah I think we're also very
fortunate in our position uh that we
don't have to work a nine to five that
makes definitely hanging out people
easier I mean I'd argue we're working
longer
but we're more flexible yeah we don't
have a boss yeah if a friend has like a
wedding you know we can be like yeah
I'll come to the wedding and yeah that's
no problem right whereas maybe another
friend couldn't go because they they
have work obligations I think maybe we
probably do work more in terms of like
if you're just looking at hours spent
it's yeah it's yeah we probably choose
we probably work a lot of over time
competitive thing but we doesn't feel
like that because we like our job it's
easy we [__] a lot of the time it's
very it's not tough yeah um but I think
that that's a very important uh
distinction to make when us three
specifically are talking about this kind
of topic because you know it's
being able to be like yeah [__] it I'll
come drink on a Wednesday like that's
like that's a a thing that we can do and
we can decide if we're capable of doing
that whereas maybe your other friend is
like I gotta go I gotta go home it's 10
p.m yeah yeah tomorrow you know and as
long as we have that but I think that
that also plays a part in our
flexibility that allows us to kind of
maintain friendships more oh I mean I
mean it's funny because you know most
most of the friends I hang out with
um you know that I do consider close
um I do I do normally do like the nine
to five schedule
um in fact a big problem has been
sometimes when friends have assumed that
I have more free time just because my
schedule yeah yeah but I found that I
find that having a schedule having a
flexible schedule as a YouTuber uh means
that I get more time to hang out with
other YouTubers yeah you know it doesn't
doesn't necessarily yeah you know what I
mean I know yeah yeah it ends up
happening a lot because I often you just
can't hang out with people all the time
who are Kingdom fives yeah so they're so
busy yeah it's like YouTube is the only
people who can like let's go [__] get
lunch on a Tuesday yeah right like right
we can do that and I think that's yeah
that's like a very fortunate thing of
our job yeah